I grew up with two girls that were like
the two girls that played with all the
boys in sports okay
fast forward they were like tomboys we
all remember tomboys right this was a
this was a thing that we're all very
familiar with now what happened to these
two girls one ended up growing up
becoming a lesbian she's a feminine
lesbian she's a woman okay the other
girl we ended up dating in high school
she's a woman in full on which is now
married with kids but like these stories
when you're seven you're ten you're 12
and you think that you're a pirate or
you think that you're a boy you're gonna
evolve like I thought I was a dinosaur
when I was seven years old I'm not
walking around you know on two legs over
here with a little arms out here but if
you don't give children the ability to
grow up and evolve and you basically
castrate them or cut them off or
harmonize them you don't give them the
ability to figure it out later on in
life and that is the truest crime